while repaving for November's F1 race is
well underway the Las Vegas Grand Prix
is just now asking Clark County to help
cover some of this huge cost the cost
that eight news now reporter Ryan
Matthey has been closely tracking found
out today is a 40 million dollar ask he
shows us what it means for Ray stake if
Commissioners don't put up that money
[Music]
traffic nightmares in and around the Las
Vegas Strip
racing to finish before Formula One and
this scene it's expected to last
throughout the summer in preparation for
the big race that both starts and ends
just on the other side of this fence
here and for months we've been asking
how much does it cost to repave the
entire circuit not only do County
Commissioners hear that price tag on
Tuesday they were also asked to cover
half of it the 40 million dollars is the
ask yes sir Stephanie Allen with the Las
Vegas Grand Prix announced the total
cost at 80 million dollars project
manager Terry Miller says why they
didn't ask for the county to cover half
sooner there were a lot of moving Parts
the only thing that wasn't moving was
November 2023 and so we had to take
action we had to continue to move this
negotiation feels a little bit too late
an answer that did not sit well with
Commissioners what's 40 million dollars
I'll tell you what in our capital budget
that's a lot
that's somebody's park that's somebody's
Recreation Center what gave you the
Comfort uh to go through this process
and and have us really be obligated to
40 million dollars there is no
obligation we're making a request today
we haven't talked directly with formula
one about any of this and now
Commissioners slimly approved a
public-private partnership that allows
the county to begin negotiating how much
money they could contribute but as chair
Jim Gibson puts it I think it's fair to
say no one should have an expectation
that half of 80 million dollars is
something that the Clark County Board of
Commissioners is going to approve or
thinks it can afford to approve